I am Catherine Pierre I am the project
assistant to Berlin science week and my
background is in art history curation
cultural studies and language studies
I think that knowledge is agency I think
to really feel empowered to change and
shape the world that we live in we need
to stay informed and we need to be
comfortable and privy to that sphere of
like science and research and debate and
so what motivates me is working on
Berlin science week extending that
invitation to join the sphere and
hopefully feel comfortable and empowered
to engage
probably making time and space in a
workload for all the exciting ideas that
we like keep having